when I saw all the drama unfolding the
ad tyronn lue being fired and then you
clean house with the Cleveland Browns
with Hugh Jackson and also Todd Haley
you know who I thought of I thought of
our old buddy Bill Livingston
semi-retired sports columnist spent 34
years of a 47 year career the Cleveland
Plain Dealer bill is this why you
retired or do you wish you were still
full time I actually then the reason I
retired was the killing hours at Ohio
State Games which which is what I did
most of the Falls because of the nascar
sized crowd you had to get there early
and you stayed late and there was
enormous traffic jams it was just and
sometimes you know a game started early
enough you had to drive home after that
and it just got to be a and that in the
Cavs annual two-month run in the
playoffs with equally long hours as the
playoffs wore on I got to be too much
but you got this you know in the span of
24 hours you're firing two head coaches
it's yeah no one deserved and one not so
deserved what do you think it's
beneficial to tyronn lue that he got out
of this mess even though he didn't
deserve to be fired after six games well
probably in the big picture but it was
outrageous to fire him after six games
I saw another coach I covered another
team that well I don't cover them now
but I do write five columns a month but
when I was covering the 76ers gene Shu
was fired after six games but that was
because of off the court politics more
than anything you know he I think the
guy's a proven coach he changed the
approach of the Cavs team to play faster
and shoot more threes which you know I
thought was like leaning into you know a
hook by Joe Frazier because because
that's what the Warriors did and they
made an unprecedented come back and won
the championship and people first one in
52 years here and people kind of said
well he's a personnel coach wasn't well
so is everybody you know look Steve Kerr
said that when he said he was wasn't
surprised lue got fired because he said
we're all at the mercy of what kind of
players we have you ran a lot of
isolation plays for LeBron and Kyrie
Irving because they were both
right players in isolation set so an
isolation set three won the championship
by Irving but do you think we should be
looking more at that the ownership here
with the Calvin Brown my column well
yeah I Dan Gilbert yeah he has been you
know he's he's liked here in town
because he spent the money but he did
spend the money on players but he has
never spent the money on his front
office people I don't think he's ever
extended a general manager and the
decline began only a few days after they
failed to defend in 2017 when he let
David Griffin who was really well
respected and had done a great job and
was actually thought he was on the way
to getting called George here you know
he let him walk away he wouldn't give
him the race he deserved and you know he
LeBron had hoped that they would bring
Kyrie to summer to training camp and try
to work things out and they traded him
as I wrote yesterday for injured Isiah
Thomas and and some magic beans - you
know conference rival Boston and that
didn't sit well with LeBron and also you
know besides the fact that he had family
and business interests in in LA he never
forgot that email that that Gilbert sent
out these two guys were divided racially
culturally and politically and quite
frankly LeBron thought he was a small
man in stature and in character this is
he's talking about Dan Gilbert was small
and yes yes with the brown situation is
this LeBron liked and respected Lou yeah
then the other coach he had yeah the
brown players respect former players and
Lou was more contemporaneous than Paul
Silas his first coach as far as the
Browns situation by now oh it's the bye
week they're not you know I Haslam had
been firing and hiring and firing so
many guys that had been a revolving door
no I think he wanted to pledge some
stability but it just wasn't happening
with you I mean you know the Browns had
always been the most loved
by the fans here it sort of escapes me
given the last 20 years of why but you
know the Indians had been the World
Series and the Cavs had been to four
straight finals and won a championship
and the Browns had had discovered always
the lowest in performance had discovered
the way to go to record lows I mean can
you imagine a one a guy with a one in 31
record you know keeping his job you know
and he was 336 and one and a at the time
he was finally fired but that's why I
said we in our office politics but why
now well cause it's the bye week
it's midseason thing they can you know
do whatever they whatever magic they
think they're gonna do with with a
there's no man you know reg we were they
well it's the Browns you know but I
can't possibly defend keeping this guy
with the record he had he never should
have been brought back I agree I agree
an you arey 31 you know boy I think a
lot of people know this around the
country but on January 31 of this year
it was happy it was Hugh Jackson day
because that's one one win 31 losses yep
there you go day just like Reggie
Jackson had a month in baseball yeah I'm
just trying to is this job desirable
wait which job is more desirable the
Browns or the Cavs you know right now I
might say the Browns because the Baker
Mayfield you know I think Mayfield is
going to be a really good player and I
haven't really said that about most of
the other quarterbacks they've had I did
have high hopes for Johnny Manziel and
boy that was a that was a swing and a
Miss but you know III do think he he's
considered to have been a very good pick
around the league and and you know they
have they have a pretty good defense
they just that you know there was no
there was no spirit around it was with
Hugh and he was a buck passer and all
you could get for him from him was
platitudes and incredibly he threw a
Isaiah Crowell under the bus after he
ran for 59 yards and said well anybody
you you and I on any of us in the in the
media room could
to run through that hole and you know lo
Hugh probably could have beat me easily
but you know I think I could have taken
anybody in a leg cast or on a walker but
you know it was it was just stupid to
have done that and it really offended
crow l who made nicey-nice a couple of
weeks later but why would you do that
you know he was your best friend why did
they trade hide you know I know they
wanted to give chub more carries but
hybrid is a tremendous short yardage
player why not have both guys I don't
understand a lot of stuff they do
they've been terrible for 20 years for a
reason and just you know with Mayfield
maybe there's maybe there's some like
finally yeah hopefully you get in a
coach who has respect and has proven
success and you get in an offensive
coordinator who is gonna be able to get
in Baker Mayfield zere soar like Shawn
McVeigh with Jared golf I think you do
never gonna get a you're probably not
gonna get a head coach here man Jeannie
was one but you know why why would you
take this job it's the most forlorn
franchise in the league you know it'll
probably be another coordinator and you
know hopefully one that is on the rise
and they can get it done well I don't
know maybe I maybe I hold out hope I I
mentioned that maybe Mike McCarthy and
the Packers separate divorce well and
then he's got a relationship with done
John Dorsey and maybe I'll get a chance
to work with 32 jobs in the NFL you know
I I remember when when the Indians were
awful in the in the 80s before you know
before the resurrection with the new
ballpark dan O'Brien the executive vice
president said said once this is the
last stop before the desert well right
now bill Hope semi-retirement is
treating you well and thank you for
joining in thank you for having me as
always high but that's a bill Livingston
semi retired man that make me want to
come back I think 34 years they're
writing about Cleveland sports and
Cleveland Plain Dealer for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]